welcome to the hugging face task series
in this video we'll take a look at the
image classification task
image classification is the task of
assigning a class to an image image
classification models take an image as
an input and return a class label
the model assumes that images only
contain one class instance per image
image classification models are
evaluated on the usual classification
metrics in addition to a more obvious
metric like accuracy a common metric
used is the f1 score which is calculated
over the average of two metrics called
precision and recall
the f1 score takes into consideration
class imbalance in your data set so it's
a better indication of how your model is
making predictions across an imbalanced
data set an example data set used for
this task is scifar
here we can see each image is paired
with its associated label
image classification is used for a wide
range of problems from medical imaging
to remote sensing
an example application is determining
whether a ct scan contains cancerous
tissues or not
for more information on the image
classification task check out the task
pages